[Musique]
pouvez-vous me dire où se trouve le
bureau du directeur
c'est vraiment absurde excusez-moi
monsieur là-bas
monsieur pouvez-vous me dire où le
bureau du directeur s'il vous plaît
monsieur
pouvez-vous me dire le
bureau du directeur vous savez où c'est
Monsieur
comment quand par qui a été créé le
musée Grévin je pense que le mieux
serait de poser la question à son
fondateur
[Applaudissements]
je suis Arthur Meyer directeur du
journal Le Gaulois
c'est moi qui ai eu l'idée de fonder le
musée Grévin en 1882 mais Arthur Meyer
est mort depuis longtemps évidemment
puisqu'il est né en 1844 il aurait donc
aujourd'hui 136 ans
quand il a fondé le musée il avait 38
ans
et il l'a fondé en 1882
et oui
cette bonne vieille maison va bientôt
fêter son centenaire
mais moi je me sens toujours aussi jeune
et en pleine forme mais qui était Alfred
Grévin
Arthur Meyer va sûrement vous le dire
mon ami Alfred Grévin lui était un
dessinateur caricaturiste plat d'humour
c'est
mon idée là emballé
et il a donné son nom au nouveau musée
comment sont fabriqués les personnages
de cire Pascal l'un des sculpteur qui
travaille pour le musée Grévin sa faire
lorsque nous pénétrons dans son atelier
secondé par ses assistants autour de la
statue en terre d'une femme assise
[Musique]
sur le corps de cette femme il délimite
à l'aide de petites plaques métalliques
les différentes parties qui vont
constituer l'ensemble d'un moule en
plâtre
ce moule de plâtre servira à la
fabrication d'un mannequin
identique à la statue qui sera réalisée
en carton épais et très dur dans un
Atelier Voisin
creux à l'intérieur ce corps présentera
le double avantage d'être léger et
résistant
après on montre les cultures
seules seront exécutés en cire les
parties apparentes de chaque personnage
[Musique]
Pascal et son équipe travaillent
actuellement à la réalisation d'un
tableau qui représentera un coin de
l'aérogare Orly et une passerelle et
avec une grande peinture dans le fond en
circulaire demi circulaire tous les
personnages que vous voyez là la
l'hôtesse de l'air vous avez vu le corps
tout à l'heure là qui est là ensuite
marie-Christine Barrault sera ici avec
un petit enfant il y aura un autre
personnage qui regardera qui sera Louis
de Funès ici un autre personnage qui
sera un marin qui passe un autre tout ça
ce sont des gens anonymes là peut-être
qu'on mettra Yves Montand ici debout
alors pour faire le portrait le buste de
Marc Christine Barrault vous l'avez
rencontré combien de fois comment est-ce
que ça se passe j'ai rencontré
marie-Christine Barrault il y a quatre
jours à peu près
elle est venue me voir ça a été décidé
avec Rosine Thomas tu es je l'ai prise
en photo avec quelques photos de son
portrait et j'ai travaillé d'après ces
photos et de là bon on part au modèle
latin on essaye de s'y rapprocher le
plus près possible et quand le modèle
vient en une heure une heure et demie on
a le temps de donner le caractère
principal
[Musique]
une tête d'homme comme ça
enlevez vous les cheveux rasez vous que
vous allez voir
j'ai pas un bonnet comme ça
moi je trouve pas
au bon moment du calcaire
[Musique]
et les rides est-ce que vous faites les
rides aussi
ça se voit pas
[Musique]
de
jeunes filles
on éprouve quand on sait qu'on va
figurer dans un tableau au musée Grévin
bah c'est un peu bizarre parce que le
musée Grévin on s'entend pas à y être à
mon âge d'abord pour moi ça t'était
amusé historique le musée que vaginal
quand j'étais petite puis j'y amène mes
enfants ça a beaucoup amusé mes enfants
l'idée qu'ils allaient me voir au Musée
non disons que au début j'ai pas bien
compris pourquoi on me demandait ça à
moi et puis je crois que maintenant que
je vois comment Pascal travaille avec un
groupe comme ça bon c'est un petit peu à
la fois le monde du cinéma et le monde
d'aujourd'hui Orly les voyages après
tout pourquoi pas moi je veux dire je le
prends un peu comme une chose comme ça
amusant
quelle impression est-ce que ça vous a
fait de découvrir votre visage en terre
alors là ça m'a fait une impression
carrément bizarre vous voyez très très
bizarre parce que
d'abord j'ai pas de cheveux là alors
donc ça me change beaucoup et surtout
j'ai oui bien sûr faut les imaginer mais
c'est difficile et puis j'ai pas Dieu
non plus et je pense que l'expression
des gens c'est beaucoup dans les yeux
donc j'ai l'impression d'un visage un
peu mort mais c'est le reste je découvre
je crois que c'est assez juste pas
mettre tout ça enfin j'ai l'impression
de me voir sur mon lit de mort ça
m'inquiète pas pour le moment
sur le plan de l'équilibre des parties
en politique est-ce que vous n'avez pas
trop de difficultés à avoir toujours
dans vos rangs de la droite à la gauche
un échantillonnage complet vous y pensez
oui nous y pensons vraiment parce que
nous ne voulons pas être taxés et de
faire de la politique on fait d'homme
politique il y en a un qui a disparu
très brutalement chez vous ces derniers
temps voulez-vous nous rappeler ce qui
s'est passé ah oui l'enlèvement de
Georges Marchais et bien c'est une
histoire assez curieuse nous avions
demandé à Georges Marchais s'il
accepterait de poser dans le tableau
d'elkabba charbitrant le débat
Mitterrand bar Le l'accord avait été
obtenu et le tableau a donc été inauguré
avec son personnage et lui restait une
vingtaine de mois sans incident notable
et puis une vingtaine de jeunes gens au
crâne rasé on fait irruption dans le
musée et ont enlevé Georges Marchais au
nez à la barbe de nos gardiens et ont
filé dans le passage Jouffroy à toute
allure on a retrouvé Georges Marchais la
fausse des ours au Jardin des Plantes à
partir d'une tête réalisée en terre par
le sculpteur on a fabriqué un épais
moule de plâtre dans lequel écoulé de la
cire chaude en se refroidissant la cire
va se durcir sur sa périphérie
c'est-à-dire contre la paroi du moule
[Musique]
quelques heures suffisent au complet
refroidissement et l'on peut alors
ouvrir le moule
à cette tête de cire plusieurs
opérations vont donner ensuite
l'apparence de la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
déjà votre main
vous avez une idée de la couleur de la
peau qu'elle avait
qu'à la tête pour la sortir avec les
mains c'est une fille qui vit en plein
air je pense que les couleurs
à l'huile comme le maquillage d'une
jeune femme mais au lieu d'employer du
phare vous employez de la peinture à
l'huile
[Musique]
c'est le moment où la ressemblance
apparaît c'est le moment le plus
agréable
tes cheveux ce sont des cheveux
synthétiques non jamais ce sont des
vrais il faut combien de temps pour
implanter une chevelure comme celle de
Madame de lavallière au 2 à 3 jours les
cheveux longs sont très loin implantés
est-ce qu'il y a des personnages que
vous n'aimez pas du tout maquillés qui
ne vous plaisent pas du tout vous avez
une antipathie parfois c'est pas une
antipathie mais les barbus ne sont pas
très drôles parce que la peinture c'est
pas très drôle de mettre autour de la
barre la plupart de nos contemporains
représentés au musée Grévin ont dû se
soumettre à cette séance de moulage de
leurs mains ce procédé en apparence très
simple permet une reproduction rapide et
parfaitement fidèle
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est de l'huile de
paraffine c'est très bon pour la peau
d'avoir une peau magnifique
plongez la main
[Musique]
vous prenez votre position
bon alors vous avez posé votre main et
vous attendez 10 minutes que la prise se
fasse
[Musique]
vous glissez tout doucement
voilà
voilà il y a plus qu'à attendre quelques
heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais dites-moi madame croisicant vous
n'avez pas de personnage nouveau à créer
parce qu'on en crée pas tous les jours
au musée Grévin à quoi pensez-vous votre
temps vous savez la maison est grande et
il y a énormément de réparation à faire
l'entretien
et que vous en train de faire à cette
oreille une réparation une femme de
ménage reculer un peu trop près du mur
au bout de laurier est parti on lui en
fait
et quand vous aurez arrangé tout ça ce
sera absolument invisible pas visible
on ne peut pas faire une réparation au
milieu du visage mais comme c'est une
réparation sur une partie comme ça qui
est un peu dissimulé aucun problème
Rosine Thomas c'est vous qui êtes
responsable des quelques 400 costumes
qui se trouve dans ce musée oui et
l'entretien en est assez considérable
parce qu'il y a énormément de poussière
et que la lumière brûle à la longue les
tissus et il faut les remplacer
naturellement toujours dans le même
style
vous devez créer un personnage comment
procédez-vous ce qui est très
passionnant c'est justement cette
recherche de documents parce qu'on
essaye d'être le plus précis possible
dans de choix rien que des tissus c'est
une des difficultés d'ailleurs parce
qu'il y a des tissus qui sont très
difficiles à trouver à certaines époques
il y a des vogues beaucoup plus
qu'autrefois et bien il y a des périodes
où je trouve alors je fais des réserves
Même si je ne fais pas tout de suite les
robes elle est bleue gris bleue avec un
galon doré dessus
elle doit être plus à gauche parce que
c'est dans l'ordre historique
bon alors là il faut pas que ce soit
trop serré parce que ça n'est pas un
tour de cou mais c'est pour mettre sur
les épaules oui ça s'arrête juste au
décolleté
avez-vous une préférence marquée pour
une époque plutôt que pour une autre
dans le costume
j'aime masser la période pour les femmes
de François 1er et puis pour les hommes
les romantiques et empire même aussi ça
présente quoi pour vous le musée Grévin
ça représente presque une grande famille
au fond une grande famille historique je
pense que des costumes modernes lorsque
vous devez habiller Simone Veil ou
Valéry Giscard d'estain c'est vous qui
choisissez le vêtement oui toujours je
vais en général dans des maisons de
couture quelquefois les maisons de
couture en gros de prêt à porter de luxe
et je cherche m'approcher du style de la
personne en question on ne vous avait on
ne vous a jamais fait le reproche d'une
cravate qu'on aimerait pas ou d'une
paire de chaussures
ça peut t'arriver ça peut t'arriver j'ai
eu des critiques sur les chaussures de
Giscard d'Estaing par exemple qui
n'était pas assez assez président de la
République probablement
ça va
dites-moi mademoiselle ça n'est pas
impressionnant de brosser comme ça le
costume du président de la République
non j'aime bien ça me plaît beaucoup
c'est intéressant c'est vous qui le
faites tous les jours ah oui tous les
matins
sauf le dimanche sauf le dimanche
et c'est la statue que vous préférez
j'aime bien
quels sont les autres personnages que
vous aimez ah j'aime bien
Louis de Funès
j'aime bien aussi le président Jimmy
Carter
est-ce que ça n'est pas un peu
impressionnant d'être toute seule dans
cette galerie avec tous ces personnages
de cire enfin quand on est habitué ça va
tout seul
les premiers temps ah oui moi je vivais
toute la nuit
[Musique]